I wish these were anomalies they're not
joining us now Vivek ramaswamy uh GOP
Presidential candidate obviously vague a
lot of this is due to lenient policies
put in place by local Democratic leaders
we know that what could be done on the
national level
so look I think we can stop subsidizing
these bad behaviors at the local level
Brian I don't think localities should
get money block grants from the federal
government unless they're allowing cops
to do their jobs we know how to address
crime in this country more cops on the
street literally on the street without
being able to look over their shoulder
fear of being sued that's thing number
one and thing number two is Bring Back
mental health institutions we have a
mental health epidemic across this
country over the same period that we saw
the closure of mental health
institutions we've seen a spike in
violent crime in this country that
doesn't mean drugging up a bunch of
people with Zoloft and Seroquel it
actually means restoring purpose
faith-based approaches and otherwise
right but those are Politically
Incorrect discussions right now cops
doing their jobs in mental health
institutions I say bring both of those
things back that's how we address
violent crime the president tried to use
federal troops to help out places like
Portland and Seattle and he was vilified
for it now you see the results I talked
to Kevin O'Leary this morning he's got a
great economic mind and obviously from
Shark Tank and I asked him about
binomics and he says the problem is the
money keeps going to corporations here's
what he said would work and here's
what's not listen
small guy the business between five and
five hundred employees he's been cut off
at the Regional Bank level the rates
that he pays for money have gone from
four to five percent to 11 to 17.
Meanwhile we're going to write two
trillion dollars to the big guys but it
seems unfair to me to support a behemoth
company that has a lot of its employees
outside of America and not my companies
small business the regulations got so
strong on the because of the failed
Regional Banks the ones that survived
can't lend money the rates are so high
small businesses can't get money even to
float a payroll it doesn't seem like
this Administration knows how to balance
a budget or run a dry cleaner a deli or
a restaurant
so look the fact of the matter is prices
have shot up wages have not people are
feeling the pain and the answer is by
Dynamics is really only working in name
because of the optical illusion they've
created by government spending in
picking favorites the number one sector
that expanded jobs Brian in the first
half of this year was actually the
government itself that's the same
government that's picking favorites in
the private sector if you're in the
electric vehicle business or in some
sort of climate change driven business
great they'll shower government Aid on
you but small businesses across this
country that aren't playing that game
that can't afford to lobby for their
business from the federal government
they're the ones left holding the bag
and so what I think we need a Revival of
in this country Brian is true capitalism
not the crony capitalism where you see
large companies lobbying for special
regulations that insulate them from
competition from one sector after
another from banking to frankly electric
vehicles but what we actually need in
this country is one standard of the rule
of law applied to every company let them
compete let capitalism once again be the
system that lifts all people up from
poverty I'm sure you saw a leader Mitch
McConnell real quick freeze up for the
second time maybe even the third after
his concussion that wiped him out for a
while in a statement they said uh
McConnell is okay now that he's
medically clear to continue his schedule
as planned uh between that between
fetterman being basically unable to put
the sentence together or communicate and
who knows how well he's thinking we see
that Dianne Feinstein is not close to
being all there and we see the president
doesn't know how to walk off a stage
what does that tell you about where
we're at now with our politicians
well look in Mitch McConnell's case I
want to pray for his recovery and hope
he and his family are doing well but
let's separate that from a separate
issue we have going on in this country
we need a generational change in who
actually leads this country forward
there's a reason why young people are
badly disaffected by politics and Brian
the examples you raise those are just
symptoms of a deeper mentality shift
that we need in this country we're not
going to move this nation forward by
just reciting slogans we memorized 30
years ago we're going to have to wake up
to the unique challenges of the present
that part of why I'm in this race I
understand why young people are badly
disaffected by politics and I do think
it's going to take a different
generation of leadership to move this
nation forward and I think you know the
guy that you had in mind when you said
that to lead that generation vague
ramaswamy you've taken uh you've become
a Rock Star Overnight big crowds a lot
of critics a lot of fans uh you brought
it on yourself pal you used to be able
to live a very peaceful life the big
Rama Swami best of luck on the trail hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else